[Music]
it seems Rihanna will be steering clear
of snapchat for quite some time the 30
year old singer just responded to the
social media apps apology for running an
ad for a game called would you rather
which asked users if they would rather
slap Rihanna or punch Chris Brown in
2009 Brown was arrested for domestic
violence and subsequently charged with
felony assault for attacking RiRi
he pleaded guilty and completed the
court-mandated community service on
Thursday Rihanna took to Instagram
stories with this message for snapchat
criticizing them for letting down
victims of domestic violence I'm just
trying to figure out what the point was
with this mess I'd love to call it
ignorance but I know you ain't that dumb
you spent money to animate something
that would intentionally bring shame to
DV victims and made a joke of it she
concluded writing shame on you throw the
whole apology away meanwhile here's the
apology snapchat issued via the BBC on
Tuesday quote the advert was reviewed
and approved in error as it violates our
advertising guidelines we immediately
removed the ad last weekend once we
became aware we are sorry that this
happened et has reached out to Chris
Brown's lawyer for comment
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]